c'est là que quelques familles de harkis
reparte à zéro chaque foyer est
propriétaire d'une baraque de
contreplaqué de 9 mètres sur 3 c'est
malgré tout la vie de camp en vase clos
une vie de camp pour des milliers de
harkis ces algériens qui avaient choisi
de combattre aux côtés de l'armée
française pendant la guerre d'algérie
considérés comme des traîtres dans leur
pays ces hommes et leurs familles
n'avaient d'autre choix que l'exil après
l'indépendance en 1962 ces rapatriements
d'urgence les autorités françaises
n'étaient pas vraiment préparé alors
pour loger ces français musulmans
rapatriés comme on les appelait à
l'époque plusieurs camps de transit sont
installées à la hâte
parfois même dans des anciennes prisons
l'ancienne prison militaire de la rue de
la mitterie à nantes un bâtiment
désaffecté devenu le refuge de 34
familles de harkis conditions difficiles
et piles besoin de le dire et de le
préciser sur ces images promiscuité
insalubrité malnutrition un quotidien
que de nombreuses familles tenteront
rapidement de fuir certaines rejoindront
des villages souvent très isolés ou des
hameaux forestier pour y travailler mais
les conditions de vie restent sommaires
cet ancien art qui en voulait au
gouvernement français nous avons
confiance au gouvernement qui nous a
donné à 1958 et 1959 à 1960 qui nous a
des beaux arts français comme vous allez
demeurer français jusqu'au bout alors on
arrivant là et ne semble prouver d'aller
bayonne plantés dans les rivières alors
c'est ça la récompense des français
qu'ils ont bien pensé pour nous
un isolement qui ne favorise pas non
plus les échanges avec les populations
locales
bien qu'ils soient français les
discriminations coloniale persiste et le
racisme règne dans certains villages
difficile dans ces conditions de trouver
sa place dans la société française un
sentiment qui perdura aussi pour les
enfants de harkis
on n'est pas encore ni comme des
français à part entière on a reconnu
comme des français ont un diamant pas on
ne considère pas comme français ont dû
rejeter on est des arbres c'est tout il
faudra attendre 1987 pour que le
gouvernement français réagissent face au
mal être des familles de harkis
de même qu'ils sont des français les
français comme tous les autres n'est
plus ni moins les français musulmans
sont aussi des rapatriés à part entière
ça c'est vrai et c'est en qualité de
président de la république que jacques
chirac instauré en 2001 la journée
nationale d'hommage aux harkis le 25
septembre de chaque année
[Musique]